[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to vr drop zone live in the
bleach report app it's futures week here
at br betting my name is kathy richards
joined by nfl expert connor rogers and
on sundays
you can find g-money holding down the
nightclub at raiders stadium
that is greg ivory he's the mayor of
many places
uh specifically us in las vegas okay
we've teamed up with draftkings to give
you an in-depth look
at our favorite nfl futures bets we're
also giving out a thousand
dk dollars we got free burgers for a
year
courtesy of chad ochocinco johnson he's
so generous
and and as always we're getting your
wardrobes tight
and we've got some hoodies that give
away g money
cabbie for all the new people that just
tapped into the show
connor this right here is the handy
dandy ipod
ipad and this is how you guys get your
hoodies i'm in the comments i am in the
comments
uh giving away a hoodie i got skate
s-k-a-t-e
got the alvin kamara gift going on
looking uh
looking up at us uh there it is you guys
can see it on the screen
but uh shout out to you s-k-a-t-e
you're walking away with a hoodie to
kick things off okay let's let's look
back at our favorite moments from last
season with the help of you
our fans
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pure unadulterated joy we cannot wait
for the nfl season to start which is
september
the 9th but there's plenty action to be
had right now we're going to start off
with
getting into our favorite futures bets
and show you the latest odds from
everything from win totals
to super bowl futures to player
performances so
uh let's start with this connor what is
the most surprising thing about this
year's schedule drop
i'm just wondering who's gonna knock
down the door week one right you got
teams that are matching up that are
coming in and trying to show that
they're for real like the browns they
get to go to kansas city and you wonder
there's a lot of hype in the browns
right now and the chiefs did a great job
building that offensive line up and
keeping continuity there
but the browns are a team that can
legitimately challenge in the afc this
year and i wonder if they surprised some
people week one and then you look at the
bills
they don't want to be known as a
one-year wonder they think they're here
to stay
so i think with josh allen a really
really well-coached defense against the
steelers team that a lot of people are
wondering
is this the end for big ben or can they
make one more serious run this year
well they got to go to the bill's mafia
to get that done and i think those are
the two matchups
uh speaking of a jump i can't wait to
see people jumping through tables in
buffalo uh the futures are now so let's
dive in
first up is win totals for the eight
most popular teams
here is the menu chicago at the top
dallas tampa bay
kc san francisco philadelphia pittsburgh
cleveland
there's some plus money on the board
which is always nice there's some under
totals
the big team missing from our top eight
here is green bay
the packers are off the board due to
some uncertainty with aaron charles
rogers so
conor can you give us your best sense
about what's going on in green bay
and how many games is aaron rodgers
worth to the betting market
well it's a stare down and obviously a
lot considering green bay is off the
board and when you look at it roger's
telling people that he doesn't plan on
coming back
green bay telling anybody that'll call
we're not planning on trading him right
now so
you have to keep the packers completely
off the board because of that cabin
you look how it could really shake
things up in the afc obviously green bay
would never move aaron rodgers i don't
think within the
nfc aaron rodgers ends up on denver what
does that win total look like if jon
gruden gets his wish and he ends up with
the raiders
what does that look like so this can
totally rock the preseason betting world
i just think these two sides are going
to stare at each other a lot longer
an mvp and a jeopardy host aaron rodgers
is excellent
at everything so uh g-money can you give
me the comment section for 200 please
let's put the odds back up let's get the
odds back up there
um get in the comments tell us your best
win total bet you can tell me in words
you can tell me gifts you can tell me
any emojis
i'm giving away hoodies and 250 dk
dollars right now uh connor what is your
favorite
win total future well let's not forget
here 17 game schedule don't be afraid of
that high number for the chiefs at 12
and a half
go over it and you get rewarded for
being bold it's plus 123. take those
favorable odds
i mean do we really think the chiefs are
gonna lose five or six games this year
better offensive line best quarterback
on the planet
great head coach a defense that makes
plays in a timely fashion
i think the chiefs get the 13 wins i'm
not sweating it at all
i know it's crazy to go with a number
that high but
i don't think it's that big of a deal
there connor rogers i like what you're
saying my dude um
i'm leaning i'm sticking in the afc as
well but i'm looking at the cleveland
browns who have an improved defense and
pro football focus
rates the cleveland browns offensive
line as tops in the nfl
so with a healthy nick chubb he he
balances the offense he's good for like
a dozen touchdowns and um
so give me the plus money give me 11
wins and the plus 107
for the for the cleveland browns uh uh
greg what are they saying in the
comments
gabby the comments they're jumping in
the comments i got roll tide giving us a
gift
i got roll tide shout out roll tide
giving us a gift of the eagles eagles
defense putting in that work
shout out to you uh i got ff football
saying green bay is going to keep rogers
cabbie over 11 wins for the packers if
he's there
shout out to you f football uh you were
walking away with
the the two people that i just mentioned
you guys are walking over hoodie this
next commenter you were walking away
with 250
in dk dollars uh little drum roll a
little drum roll here we go here we go
i have i have uh
ak-47
come on cabbie something serious you're
gonna think you're gonna think i was
being uh
i was being biased here but i really
wasn't this was the first person i saw
he said the san francisco 49ers over uh
i promise you that was that was not
biased that was strictly from the from
the comments
uh but you guys you guys are taking over
i see cabbie with the cleveland over i
see my guy conor with the kansas city
over
i'm gonna switch it up a little bit i'm
gonna switch it up a little bit i'm
gonna take the tampa bay
bucks under uh it's plus money it's plus
money i do
see a super bowl hangover here okay i
see a super bowl hang over here with
this team
uh so yeah give me the under i i like it
it's plus money
and i'm riding it i like that g money
that's a big swing my g
uh visit draftkings for more win more
wins totals odds and uh
place your bets because we've hooked it
up with draftkings they're basically
letting you guys move the market
so this is how it works you bet your
favorite nfl win total over at draftking
sportsbook
at the end of the week whichever team
has the most win totals bets
will have one win total knocked knocked
off
okay um so the current lead is minnesota
so the minnesota
fan base is flooding dk we like to see
it uh
with washington and chicago close behind
so get in there and
bet your favorite win total to move the
line
if you didn't get those dk dollars don't
worry we're giving away more stuff
right now g-money yes sir yes sir we
tapped in with chad we tapped in in chat
and asked them to predict the win total
for the bengals next season
the current line is six and a half it's
at six and a half get in the comments
drop over
or under tell me whether you think chad
has faith in the bengals
or if he doesn't if you know 85
cabbie you know him well he loves to eat
mcdonald's he loves his mcdonald's
uh so we're giving out a hundred dollars
in mcdonald's
money courtesy of chad johnson to
whoever guesses correctly
uh connor connor do you think
that the bengals will go over or under
six and a half wins i'm gonna go under
tough division right we know joe burrows
coming off an injury we're wondering
when he's really gonna be a full goal
i love that they took jamar chase i
think they're heading in the right
direction
i don't think they get to that seven win
mark yet i just think that's a lot to
ask when you're looking at the browns
and the ravens in your own division
quite frankly a very very good
conference where the schedule won't do
them any favors and i think when you
look at it
that's how i feel now i think chad's
gonna bet with a little emotion and a
little bit of heart here
and he'll go the other way so conor has
cincinnati under six and a half wins
let's go let's go to the video to see
how chad
how chad feels about his bengals knowing
burrow
who had one of his best seasons at lsu
before he left
was with who jamar chase bengals will
have over eight wins
book it
ah my god you know right he i think he
smoked about 85 of those 85 cigars on
that dude he's such a like
hey he definitely definitely did kevi
chad said
over eight wins the line is six and a
half so someone who took me over someone
in the comments that took the over is
walking away
with the hundred dollars in mcdonald's
money courtesy of my guy chad johnson
i'm going to get in the comments right
now let me get in the comments right now
um
here we go i got em go blue and go blue
16
set over shout out to you you're walking
away with a hoodie um i
also have evan evan lk
evan lk who day baby way over six and a
half
and with the burger emoji shouts out to
you ethan you were walking away with a
hoodie
uh cabbie it's time to get to this
hundred dollars in mcdonald's
money courtesy of my guy chad johnson uh
shaquille shaquille oatmeal shaquille
o'neal
you are the winner of the stand
outstanding
dollars uh courtesy of my guy chad
johnson to mcdonald's you're you're the
first winner shout out to my guy
shaquille
meal hopefully you can get a an egg
mcmuffin or whatever breakfast treats
you like you you get you get them all at
mcdonald's
so we have we have uh uh a lot more to
give away including a free year of
burgers
courtesy of chad ochocinco so let's keep
it moving and talk
the odds to win the division we're gonna
look at one of the most hotly contested
divisions
the nfc leased none of these teams even
got to 500 last year the entire division
was a disaster
dallas is the betting favorite at plus
125 then the washington football team
plus 260
the football giants from new york plus
350 and then philadelphia at plus
500. greg how does the audience feel
about the nfc leased
let me ask them cabbie i like how you
call them the nfc least
get in the comments tell us who you
think is a lot to win the nfc east
you can tell me however you guys want
get creative there's four different
teams in the conference
you guys get creative in the comments
let me know who you think is going to
win i'm giving away hoodies and i'm also
giving away 250
dk dollars this time connor what's your
take who do you think is winning the nfc
well when you look at it considering you
get favorable odds or whoever you bet i
think they have no idea who's going to
win this division either one of the more
ones that are up in the air
i love washington i look at the football
team and just see
the most complete team across the board
in this entire division i think that
when you look at the defense you had
william jackson now you have a shutdown
corner
you have a front four that gets after
the quarterback i think the quarterbacks
have a lot of question marks in this
division as a whole
they got a lot more athletic in the
middle of the field with the pick of
jamin davis
ron rivera great head coach ryan
fitzpatrick can get those weapons
working down the field whether it's
scary terry whether it's curtis samuel
and they got a run game and an improved
offensive line so washington football
team plus 260.
that one that might be one of my
favorite futurist bets that's available
right now
connor how much magic do you think fitch
magic has left like has
is the magic gone at this point the
guy's like 40.
he had it for miami last year he had to
be the closer for cua in a lot of games
and that team
that's right uh you know i really want
to take philadelphia look at the plus
500 the odds are long and they're
juicy um and they the eagles have the
easiest strength of schedule
but there's just so much pressure to put
on jalen hurts a quarterback who's only
played four games in the nfl so
i'm gonna go to the top of the board uh
the teamwork that brought in a new
defensive coordinator
will have a pair of healthy uh tackles
in lyle collins and tyron smith
and this squad used eight of its 11
draft picks to address
the poorest defense that we saw in 2020
so i'm going with the dallas cowboys i
know that makes me a chalk eating weasel
but i think the cowboys take the nfc
east this season give me that at plus
125.
g money what are they saying on the on
the handy dandy ipad
cabbie they're getting creative in the
comments they are getting creative in
the comments i got
uh i i got milwaukee 1919
saying cowboys will be under 500
washington football team
to win the division shout out to you
milwaukee 19 19 you were walking away
with the hoodie i got uh conor grant not
connor rogers but conor grant is in the
comments
he says the football team he's rocking
with you connor and the football team
shouts out to you uh it's time to give
away these 250 dk dollars gabby it's
time to it's time to give away
250 dk dollars i am in the comments and
i see uh
chris 12 c chris 12c
says cowboys he has the dak prescott gif
hopefully it doesn't leave the screen
you guys can see it right there dak
prescott there it is
uh shouts out to you uh chris
let me get my pick in here let me get my
pick in here cabbie
i'm a rock with my guy connor i'm a rock
with my guy conor the washington
football team fits magic cabbie you
asked does he have magic
i think he still has some magic left
this defense is put together the front
four is nasty connor the front four is
nasty chase young
montez sweat jonathan allen
durant pay i don't know why come on
duron pay how can i forget
uh they're number two they were ranked
number two in total yards allowed last
year
they only got better they only got
better the draft of the linebacker like
this defense is put together i like it's
magic scary terry you mentioned curtis
samuel coming over
the three-headed monster in the
backfield come on give it to me
give it to me please i like the
washington redskins plus 260. you guys
speak with so much confidence that i
i might change my pick i know i have a
little bit of time the season's still
like four
uh four months away but um you guys are
giving me something to think about
uh for the rest of you guys visit
draftkings for the remaining seven
division odds so
it's time to give away some more burgers
g money who's who's ready to eat
we asked chad we asked 85 to facetime
t.o and asked for his luck to win the
nfc
east yeah get in the comments tell us
who you think
t.o picked uh is he riding with his
favorite is he riding with the favorite
the cowboys or is he sprinkling money on
the eagles
we're giving away a hundred dollars in
mcdonald's money courtesy of my guy 85
to whoever guesses correctly connor
who do you think t.o picked do you think
he took
the eagles or do you think he took the
cowboys or do you think he took a
different team in the division i think
he's running back to the stars what i
think he's doing he's going with the
favorite in the dallas cowboys and it's
gonna be a tough toss-up for him he's
got a little eagles bias maybe he's got
a little cowboys bias maybe
but i think he's gonna rock with dallas
in this situation
all right so connor says terrell owens
is gonna lean dallas
let's check the video to see who t.o
picked
they can't see your face but they can
hear your voice my voice is good
if they see my face it's only going to
enhance what you're doing right now
he's in the dark though are you sleeping
oh it's a good one your favorite team
well the cowboys make the playoffs
they got all they got all that firepower
on offense why wouldn't they
i say yes will they win the nfc east no
what they don't have any competition
eagles these
eagles are always gonna they got jayla
hurst he's always gonna put them in
in contention wait wait a minute wait a
minute the new coach just said jalen
hurst has to compete for the starting
job
do they have faith in him oh yeah thank
you okay that's all
yeah i i know i know what he's made of
okay okay t.o is asleep you can't even
see him
but what he did do is he enhanced what
we what we're doing today because of his
good looks
my guy my guy t.o took the eagles tl
took hills that means one of you who
said
eagles is walking away with a hundred
dollars in mcdonald's
money courtesy of my guy chad johnson
himself i'm gonna get into the comments
right now i'm going to get into the
comments right now
uh br betting is in the comments they
said they're taking the football team
they're going to go bet it right now
shout out to br betting
i got ryan ryan ray says philly
rocking with philly rocking with philly
and my guy t.o
uh here we go here we go hold on i got
one more got one more
i got michael ritter michael ritter
he says the eagles coach can't even read
says the eagles coach candy v reid shout
out to you michael riddles the two
people that i just mentioned
you two are walking away with uh hoodies
now this one is for the hundred dollars
gabby this one's a hundred dollars
connor you guys are ready let me get
into this handy dandy
we have costa rica mark costa rica mark
took the eagles
and is winning those mcdollards shout
out to you
uh costa rica mark i hope i can get to
costa rica this summer
uh but shout out to you uh you're
walking away with a hundred dollars
in mcdonald's money courtesy of chad
johnson nice the uh the last time
philadelphia won the nfc was in 2017
and that was on the strength of some big
nick energy
let's talk conference winners here are
the odds to win the nfc championship
the defending super bowl champions tampa
bay buccaneers are at the top at plus
300
the la rams plus 600 san francisco
g-money's team plus c 650 there's green
bay at plus
800 with or without aaron rodgers
dallas seattle new orleans minnesota
odds are a little bit longer
still great teams greg how many people
in the comments think that tampa bay is
going to run it back
cabbie let me let me ask him let let me
actually ask him hey
people in the comments let me know if
you think tampa bay is going to run it
back get in the comments actually tell
me who you think is going to win the nfc
championship tell me who you think is
going to go to the super bowl from the
nfc
uh i'm giving away hoodies and i'm also
giving away 250
bk dollars this time connor you see that
team that was listed third
i know you see him plus 650 looking a
little juicy just a little bit
uh but but but talk to me connor who do
you think's coming out of the nfc
listen greg i'm gonna agree about with
your super bowl hangover theory i'm not
gonna take the bucks at plus 300. i
think the bucks are a great team they
got the band back together
that's just not really favorable odds
and you're betting you're risking a lot
there
i like the rams plus 600 i think you
look at matt stafford there
with sean mcvay sure they lost some
coaches on both sides of the ball
he's still the best defensive player on
the planet and aaron donald
they have a really good talented
secondary and i think stafford takes
this offense to the next level working
with mcveigh and we know when things are
clicking on offense between
sean mcvay and his quarterback he can
get back to the promised land and that's
the super bowl so love the rams at plus
600.
solid pick connor rogers uh guys i don't
have confidence in this pick
i was uh there was a whole lot of
consternation
in in when i was when i was picked
choosing this because i i want to get
the value play i want a long shot i want
i want an underdog to root for so i'm
going with new orleans
um they have a middle of the road uh
strength of schedule they have a top
five caliber defense
and here's the big thing obviously alvin
kamara
is all world but if their other
all-world player on offense michael
thomas is healthy for the whole season
then jameis winston can ball out and i'm
not saying 30 touchdown
30 interceptions maybe like 30 maybe 35
touchdowns in much less than 30
interceptions
he's on a one-year deal so you know he's
he's gunning for a new contract so
give me the new orleans saints at plus
1400 to be the
nfc champions g-money what are they
saying in the comments and
will you please tell us which team
you're rooting for even though it might
be yours
comments i'm gonna get in these comments
but uh
do you really think jameis winston's
gonna win the championship
i mean gonna he's got a huge arm and
he's got weapons alvin kamara is a
cheekbone he saw him he's not
going to start bet on is he even going
to start every week bro
oh is he going to be happy is he even
going to start yeah jason hill's right
there
i mean taysom hill is there and he's
he's one of uh he's
he's a favorite but um no it's jimmis
winston
it's jameis winston we get some cybex i
bet week one sideband
a week one starting yeah i got i'll put
100 on that
all right hunted on it here we go let me
get into these to these comments before
the producer gets into my ear here we go
jay lee 19
9 says tom brady and the buccaneers he
had the tom brady gift of him actually
walking out
of the uh the parade where he was
actually being held up by one of his uh
teammates or
whoever was holding him up shout out to
you uh jaylee199 you were walking away
with a hoodie i got sean rowan 54
says seattle wow do a curveball there
sean
seattle uh sean rowan 54 you were
walking away with a hoodie cabbie let me
give out 250 of these
dk dollars real quick let me get out 250
at his dk dollars um here we go
i see i see michael ritter's in the
comments
not gonna give it to michael not gonna
give it to michael uh
down to earth hey down to earth he's
throwing a little shade at me but he's
rocking with you cabbie so therefore i'm
gonna give you
the 250 dk dollars down to earth stop
doubting the saints they got it okay he
is uh
he's confirming what you just said down
to earth with that with all that
with all that being said with all that
being said uh
there was a team that was listed third
on the list plus 650 the san francisco
49ers
that i strongly believe this year ranked
on paper against matched up on paper
against anybody in the league
we're right we're right there the san
francisco 49ers are right there on paper
we're just a quarterback away
jimmy has competition now with trey
lance
trey lance is right behind him he's a
dog right behind him jimmy has
competition
so we're just gonna uh we're gonna let
the let the cards play play themselves
we're to see how it goes
conor said conor said something about
sean mcveigh clicking with his
quarterbacks
you can also say the same thing about
kyle shanahan
clicking with quarterbacks and uh if he
clicks with a quarterback with the
defense that we have
and also the offensive play makers that
we have devo
ayuk uh mozart i can keep going if you
guys want me to kittle didn't even name
him
but uh hey we're gonna be right there
cabbie we are gonna be right there
so take out take the niners plus 650 we
also play the rams tough
niners play the rams tough so that's why
you know i'm leaning this way
and i also think tampa bay is going to
have the hangover you can tell greg
ivory is from the bay area because he
says
we were referring to the san francisco
49ers
visit draftkings for the remaining nfc
championship
odds and i'm shocked i was trying to
remember sean payton's name for some
reason
i know tayson he loves jason hill but
it's it's the jamie
james winston era famous jameis uh
listen burgers are a staple
of ocho's diet and sharing is caring so
uh greg ivory who wants these delicious
carbs
cabbie let me find out we asked chad for
his luck
to win the afc let's take a look at the
menu
there it is there it is kansas city
sitting at plus 260.
uh buffalo wow buffalo plus 625
uh connor you see cleveland right there
plus 750
uh get in the comments tell us what team
you think chad picked
we're giving away a hundred dollars to
one of you who guessed correctly
uh while you guys vote connor tell us
who do you
like to win the afc actually this is a
hundred dollars in mcdonald's money
this is a hundred dollars in mcdonald's
money i wanted to clarify that but
connor who do you who do you like to win
the nfc of the afc i'm sorry man i like
those browns odds plus 750 and who knew
we'd be living in this year and
saying i like the brown's odds to win
the afc but they've built a phenomenon
they've gotten it right with the coach
and kevin stefanski i think the best of
baker mayfield is ahead
but they do two things that travel in
the playoffs and lead to super bowl
appearances
that's they run the ball and they're
going to play defense they got a good
first round corner and greg newsome to
round out that secondary they got miles
garrett who's just an absolute beast off
the edge
he's going to have a career gear i think
this offense will be efficient enough to
keep winning games
i know it's crazy to say especially with
the chief sitting up there
the ravens are just always around i love
what the bills mafia has done over the
years
but man i'm gonna go with the long shot
that's the browns
connor says the cleveland browns to win
the afc championship i dig it let's
let's check the tape and see if ocho
cinco is going out on a limb
as well my fire burger lock to when the
afc
is the chiefs
and it it burns me to say that but okay
[Music]
chad took the chiefs chad took the
chiefs meaning someone who said kansas
city in the comments is walking away
with the hundred dollars in mcdonald's
money courtesy of my guy chad johnson
himself
i'm in the comments right now in the
comments giving away hoodies
first i got sweena swina uh
swina is in the comments cabbie asking
what are we betting on
what are we betting on welcome
we're talking futures but guess what you
just walked into the show you probably
just came into the show but you're
walking away with a hoodie
shout out to you sweena or uh king 12
cabbie king 12
burger and american things i don't
know what that meant but guess what why
not
they tapped in they're walking away with
a hoodie thank you guys for tapping in
uh cabbie it's time to give away those
hundred dollars in that mcdonald's money
courtesy of my guy chad johnson himself
are you guys ready yes are you guys
ready yes sir uh
here we go here we go in the comments in
the comments my guy
ryan ray won a hoodie guess what he's
also walking away with some mcdonald's
money shout out to you ryan
for being here and tapping in to the
drop zone uh ryan
ray is walking away with the hundred
dollars in mcdonald's money courtesy and
my guy chad johnson
the audience loves it when you're this
generous g money keep it up uh since the
year 2000 only four players
have won the nfl mvp who were not
quarterbacks
there are only quarterbacks on this
short list of potential nfl mvps so
let's see
the menu here so we have a bunch of
former every piece patrick mahomes 2018
mvp aaron rodgers 2020 mvp tom brady
2017 mvp lamar jackson 2019
mvp this is a decorated list and you
have justin herbert who is the 2020
rookie of the year greg you're our mvp i
just don't see your odds on the board we
gotta get in touch with whoever's
running this at draftkings
but who's getting the most mvp love in
the comments
yeah we gotta figure that out we don't
be on the list not just kidding just
kidding but i need you guys to do me a
favor get in the comments let me know
who you think is a lot to win
mvp uh i'm giving away hoodies and this
time i'm giving away 250 mo
bk dollars connor you saw the list it's
juicy my guy the list is juicy stars
around
i mean stars all around the list where
are you leaning towards
mvp this season i've been giving you
long shots all show
we're keeping it simple here and going
with the guy on top and that's patrick
mahomes he's the best quarterback in the
entire
universe plus 500 that's pretty good
honestly i thought it would be much
tougher than that when you lay some
money on my homes winning the mvp
cappy said it this is the most valuable
quarterback award and nothing else so
don't waste your time
with anyone else in that regard mahomes
is gonna come back a little bit pissed
off this year i think he felt they
should have had back-to-back super bowls
tough break for him better offensive
line which was their achilles heel in
the super bowl with those injuries and
they went out and fixed that unit so
mahomes plus 500
it's pretty sweet guys we we you say
that mahomes might be pissed off we saw
what i pissed off aaron rodgers did in
2020 my guy threw for 48 touchdowns
and rogers in 2021 still pissed off the
disrespect in green bay
is crazy and that will fuel his fire if
he remains with green bay
i think that he's going to get his
fourth mvp trolley because we saw what
he could do
last year and his team his squad wasn't
even all the way healthy so
uh i like rogers at plus 900 and maybe
sprinkle a little bit on dak prescott
uh greg who's your who's your lock to
win mvp in 2021
and uh who's getting love in the
comments
gabby before i get to mine let me get
into these comments roll tides back
in the comments riding with patrick
mahomes uh you already have a hoodie
roll tide but that is okay
thank you for uh tapping in meech norris
33's
justin herbert wow then herbert
i like that ken g ken g
justin herbert i like that a lot i
actually like that a lot
uh kevin i mean uh not kevin cabby i'm
so sorry
evan i can combine you guys two names
you read it cabbie evan
cabby he said jamin winston for mvp
that kind of goes along with your uh
your future bet of winning the super
bowl
uh i mean let me give away this 250 dk
dollars real quick cubby let me give
away this 250 dk dollars
i got richie 21 richie 21
with the russell west russell wilson i'm
sorry russell wilson gift
here we go right there russell wilson
walking down uh
slapping hands with his teammates with
that being said
i'm gonna have to agree with my guy
connor rogers here
uh pat mahomes uh it's it's like he's
playing madding out there on sundays
like
literally it's like he's playing madden
out there on sundays dropping back
rolling left then rolling back right and
then throwing 50 yards down the field
he does it every sunday it seems like uh
go on youtube guys go on youtube in in
in
search patrick mahomes and that'll tell
you why you should bet on him for mvp
this season
but with that being said i saw my guy
justin herbert
it's a little sprinkle it's worth a
little sprinkles a little sprinkle
all right that's a little sprinkle but
uh i like pat though i don't know how
many
i don't know how many players have gone
from rookie the year to mvp i don't even
know if it's ever been done in the nfl
but that would be quite a feat
uh for the chargers quarterback so visit
draftkings for more
player futures including rookie of the
year we're giving away america's
favorite food from america's
favorite ambassador burgers from chad
johnson
we've got a fresh crop of talented
rookies to discuss uh
greg do we have rookies new to drop zone
in the comments
gabby we probably do have some rookies
in the comments but welcome to all
rookies it's love here
but uh we asked chad for his lock to win
offensive rookie of the year let's take
a look at the menu let's take a look at
the menu
um this menu it's it's filled it's
filled with a lot of rookies i mean
obviously it's working of the year
but it's some talented guys on here we
got trevor lawrence sitting at plus 300
uh trey lance of course plus 600
uh uh zach wilson hey connor you see
zach wilson right there
he's supposed to be starting this year
naji harris of course uh
you guys get in the comments tell us who
you think chad picked to win offensive
rookie of the year we're giving away a
hundred dollars of mcdonald's
money courtesy of my guy chad johnson to
whoever guesses correctly connor
who do you like to win rookie of the
year i'm getting away from the
quarterbacks here we're going with naji
harris workhorse running back first
round running back goes to a landing
spot that they will love to run the ball
with him as the 1a kind of guy he never
has to come off the field three down
runner can catch the ball
pass protect that's what you look for
when you're looking for these offensive
rookie of the years what can their
production be
out of the gate i know trevor lawrence
is going to start i know zach wilson is
going to start right away
i think if we knew trey lance you'll
like this greg i think if we knew trey
lance was starting week one
i think that's where my money would go
but that's too much up in the air right
now so naji harris
plus 800 i think it could be a top five
most productive running back in the
league right away
conor i love it he's got naji harris and
the pittsburgh steelers
let's look at the video to see if chad
is also rolling with a workhorse running
back
yo my fire burger lock to win rookie of
the year
will be devonta smith
chad of course he's sticking on server
right
yeah yeah of course you know 85 is go
take devonta especially somebody that's
not physical can get off the line and
use their feet you know that's what you
have
that's what he did back in the day
that's what he did back in the day so
you know he's going to try to take
somebody that you know
cabbie but uh he took devonta meaning
someone who said devonta smith
in the comments is going home with a
hundred dollars
in mcdonald's money courtesy of my guy
chad johnson himself
uh i'm about to get into these comments
let me get into these comments first i'm
gonna give away some hoodies
and then we're gonna uh talk the hundred
dollars i have uh
i have f football sets fields or chase
are great hooked
great picks uh shout out to uf football
uh julie football says i was the only
one
saying smith baby shout out to you julie
you are walking away with the hoodie i
also have uh
be hoped behold haas zero seven says
devonta
adams no no no not devonte adams i'm
sorry i'm thinking about tay
not a devonte smith devonte smith
uh not tay hopefully devonte smith turns
out to be like tay we'll see
but uh shout out to uh julie for saying
devonta smith
and uh the the other person producer
yeah the producer is gonna tell me who
won
uh we're moving on cabbie we have to see
who's gonna walk away with this hundred
dollars
in mcdonald's money we have to see who's
gonna walk away with this hundred
dollars in mcdonald's money actually
guess what i'm just going to give it to
julie i'm just going to give it to julie
why not just football
big deal football she took she took
smith and is walking away with the
hundred dollars
in mcdonald's money uh julie you were
right
you were right congratulations and
welcome to the show
super bowl 56 is scheduled for february
the 13th
in los angeles which team will be there
to hoist
the lombardi trophy let's see the odds
these are the
contenders and it starts top two
a rematch of super bowl 55.
kansas city 525 10 but bay at 650
and then the odds get a little juicier
buffalo at plus 13.
buffalo is a is a is a darling it feels
like this here
the rams at plus 1300 baltimore san fran
cleveland and green bay
round out the list uh greg what do you
want the audience to do here with these
championship
contenders get in the comments tell us
who's a lot to win the super bowl
you could tell me an emojis you can tell
me raising trophies and gifts you can
tell me teams race i don't know you guys
get creative
i don't want to tell you guys what to do
because you guys always come back with
creative uh
gifts so get creative tell me who you
guys think is going to win the nfl
championship
uh and i'm giving away 250 dk dollars
this time as well
connor who do you like the most to win
the championship
this year i like the rams now if you the
packers can figure this thing out with
aaron rodgers i know those odds will
spike up of course they will but they
won't go up enough where it would deter
me
so that's the one i have my eyes on but
just going on the bet today making that
decision today i'm gonna roll with the
rams here i'm believing in the magic
between mcvay and matt stafford
once again that defense has been playing
together for a long time
the chiefs and the bucks you always
gotta wonder with those odds is it worth
it and like you said greg
that bucks hangover we'll keep our eyes
on that it's it's
it's a long shot it's always hard to
repeat in the nfl so
rams new energy new quarterback i like
those odds as well
this strategy hasn't worked for every
team but it's worked for teams with
generational quarterbacks
on rookie deals we saw russell wilson
win a super bowl in seattle on a rookie
deal we saw patrick mahomes win a super
bowl with kansas city
on a rookie deal we will see lamar
jackson in baltimore
win a super bowl on his rookie deal um
you know he's on the final year of his
deal so he's looking for a huge payday
but it allows baltimore to be
very competitive they've resigned a
bunch of key defensive players
they've added sami watkins who's a
versatile receiver on the offensive end
they've designed baltimore's scheme to
maximize lamar jackson's talents
so i think this year contract here my
dude will probably get
somewhere between 30 and 40 million next
year but this is the year to do it
they have a they have an mvp and a
generational talent at privet
give me the baltimore ravens at plus
1400.
greg who do you like to win the super
bowl and which team is getting the most
love in the comments
cabbie they're all over the place in the
comments as usual
selena's back sweeney is back rocking
with the cardinals and kyler murray
shout out to you cameron devault
already bought the 49ers super bowl cap
shout out to you
cameron uh uh cabbie i got one more in
here and let me get one more k-pops
k-pop
is rocking with the buffalo bills k-pots
is rocking with the buffalo bills
uh let me give away this 250 dk dollars
cubby let's get it
let me give away this 250 i appreciate
your generosity
hey homie the audience definitely loves
you man you always come with gifts
of course got gotta gotta take care of
the people kevin you know i'm a man of
the people
i am a man of people uh here we go
flores nine
f flores nine a rocking with the raiders
unfortunately no i'm just kidding but uh
they said good luck containing
this offense shout out to you f flores9
you were walking away with 250
dk dollars all right here we go cabbie
what do you got my pick to win
the nfl championship i'm gonna rock with
the buffalo bill okay g money
with the buffalo bills i'm gonna rock
with the buffalo bills i like i like i
like
i like my guy allen out there like my
guy josh allen liked what he did last
year
uh their defense the defense is good
they have a really good defense my guy
stefan diggs out wide
i think they have what it takes cabbie
to knock off the chiefs
this year i do i strongly do believe
that
uh we'll see i think they'll take a big
step my guy connor talked about it
earlier in the show
he said uh he said some teams that you
know that were used to not
being good they're going to be good this
year and i strongly believe
buffalo is going to be one of those
teams so uh if the niners aren't
aren't aren't you know doing what we
supposed to be doing buffalo buffalo
like the pick everything in the nfl is
cyclical so maybe it's buffalo's time
this year we'll we'll see
uh come february of next year so visit
draftkings
for more odds to win this super bowl
it's time for the big moment
the big moment from the homie ocho cinco
greg tell them what's up
we've been giving away hundreds of
dollars in burgers all show but right
now
right now connor and cabbie it's time to
give away
free burgers for a year courtesy of my
guy
chad johnson himself we asked chad for
his luck
to win the super bowl we asked him chad
who's going to win the super bowl
get in the comments tell me who you
think he chose
to win the super bowl i'm going to pick
one of you who guesses correctly
to win free burgers for a year so while
everybody is voting let's take a peek at
what week
one has to offer we just highlighted six
marquee games six marking matchups
and it starts with the thursday night
game dallas and tampa bay we got buffalo
pittsburgh
cleveland and kansas city which should
be a a great one let's go to the next
page here
we got the jets in carolina
we'll see the the return of christian
mccaffrey hopefully he's at 100
the sunday night game the the bears at
the rams and the monday night game of
course baltimore ravens
and the las vegas raiders connor as you
look at the board here
what is your favorite week one bet i'm
chasing the overs
all the way that's what i'm looking at
right now okay yeah
i don't care about who wins who loses it
in most of these games right i'm just
looking at the overs going for points
and i think dallas and tampa bay
is it is listen that's the first game
we're gonna see of the year
defense might be a little rusty you
might not be up to speed we get the
return of dak prescott with all those
weapons
we know what brady can do with the
entire cast back i think we're in for a
shootout on night one where we go over
those 52 points
love that um i'm i'm for week one i like
my road dogs road dogs don't really get
that much love
so i'm going with the chicago bears plus
seven listen andy dalton or justin
fields
you don't have to win the game you just
have to cover the seven
points all right i know you're in tough
in la
and as conor said earlier they have the
best defensive player on planet earth
in number 99 but guys game manage
let's just get out let's get out with
under seven points
maybe buy a field goal don't have to win
the game give me the bears at plus seven
uh greg what's your favorite week one
matchup
cabbie uh i'm right there with you but
just with a different team i'm
gonna talk about the same game connor
talked about but i think i want to lean
cowboys cowboys plus six and a half uh i
talked about you know the super bowl
hangover with tampa
week one you know they're going to be
getting their rings you know
all that's going to be you know taken
into effect so i i think the cowboys
might keep this one close actually not
my i do think they're going to keep it
close so i'm willing to put my money on
the cowboys plus six and a half
everybody loves offense and hopefully we
just get
giant tubs of popcorn and that game is
like 52 to 49 or something crazy
visit uh draftkings for more week one
odds center let's get to the moment
everybody's been waiting for
free burgers for a year g-money who is
this lucky person
cabbie free burgers for a year
uh let me look let me look into these
comments i'm gonna give away some
hoodies and then i'm gonna just give
away
uh free burgers for a year here we go i
am in the comments and i see king of
sports 21 says love the panthers sam
darnold
going against his former team uh likes
the panthers week one
wow i didn't even know shouts out to you
king of sports
uh shouts out to you uh cabbie actually
let me pull up a video let me pull up
this video real quick yeah
before we get let me pull up this video
real quick let's pull up the video guys
my five burger lock to win the super
bowl
tampa bay if the tampa bay buccaneers
don't win the super bowl
because they have tom so they have the
greatest chance regardless of what
any other teams do i'll give up
mcdonald's
what's that chad took tampa bay cavi
chad took
tampa bay so someone who took the bucks
someone who took the bucks is walking
away with free burgers for a year cabbie
i know i'm going to get in these
comments did you what go ahead kevin go
ahead
listen it's it's it's uh i love i love
ojo's confidence
and uh he does take sometimes take some
bold swings with super bowl predictions
but going back to back that's like i
mean conor said like it's so hard to do
and then nfl and chad played in the nfl
so he knows personally how hard it would
be for a team
to win back to back i don't know man
tampa uh
you know great squad everybody's
returning they made sure they
resigned all their vets i don't know
connor what do you think about that
that super bowl pick you just don't get
that kind of injury luck
year after year that's what the problem
is especially when you're an older team
which they have a lot of young talent
there's no doubt about that
but at key positions they are definitely
a veteran team and
i know they're a deep roster especially
at wide receiver
and they have a really good offensive
line but i just always have fear with
super bowl
champions coming into another year and
hoping to stay that healthy again and
that's why i stay away because
the odds aren't in your favor and often
with injuries the luck's not in your
favor
do you mind let me get back into these
comments let me get back
i mean i've been saying it all show
kathy i don't think tampa bay is going
to win uh
i think they're going to have a super
bowl hangover but
let me get back into these comments
because uh we're at one of the most
important parts of the show
we're going to give away burgers for a
whole year here
uh richie rich 21 says back to back
let's get it shout out to you richie
rich
uh word w-i-r-g
said uh let's go let's go
i mean let's go shout out to you i'll
give you a hoodie just for your let's go
good vibes uh here we go pierre pierre c
pierre c say if they make it to the
super bowl yeah there ain't no stopping
brady
uh i totally agree i totally agree
let me get away these these free burgers
for a year cabbie all right here we go
next one i'd select is free burgers for
a year here we go
person that's winning free burgers for a
year is king
12 king 12 king 12
uh they said tampa bay they rock it with
tampa bay
tom brady chad johnson shout out to king
12.
you were walking away with free burgers
for a year enjoy those delicious carbs
oh i'm so jealous if you learned
anything today
let it be that you don't have to wait
for the football season to get in on the
action
get on draftkings and bet your favorite
futures and be sure to bet the win
totals for your favorite team draftkings
has hooked us up
and giving an odds boost to the team
most bet and knocking a win
off of the total uh g-money do you want
to give away a few more hoodies before
we get out of here
uh why not why maybe maybe maybe two
more maybe two more
behold hoss 07 could see brady finishing
fish in his career going back to back
shout out to you great take care uh
skip jones skip jones says tampa went on
the hot streak
it won't happen again this year shout
out to you skip jones you were walking
away with a hoodie uh
cabbie that's two got you yeah i'm gonna
get up out of here
that john elway walking off on the
sunset back-to-back championships would
be
incredible and the perfect ending for
tom brady's career
if he wants to retire it feels like the
guy still wants to play until 50
and of course we'll all see and we'll
all be uh cheering him on because he's
legendary
listen alongside the legendary greg
ivory and the legendary
connor rogers my name is cabbie richards
congrats to all of our winners and
everybody
who tapped in for br drop zone while
you're cooking up futures of your own
take a look at two very different but
equally valid
approaches making picks from our friends
over at dropkicks
there's a lot of mvp talk going around
the game of football
okay hear me out the g harris i don't
listen to other people
i make my own predictions the running
game was nowhere to be found for the
steelers last year
he's probably going to be pittsburgh's
top running back
and with that workload he can get 20
plus touches a game
that equals stats you're welcome
[Music]
you